[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is a Windows Phone 8 handset this
is the Nokia Lumia 925 a lot of people
have asked me to review a Windows Phone
8 device not just because it's Windows
Phone 8 but because it's coming from the
perspective of someone like me who uses
a lot of Google services I use Google
Tasks Google Calendar Gmail a lot of
things like that that make it really
really good for Android now Windows
Phone 8 has come out and it's been
around for a while but I've never really
tried it out because I've never really
seen all the customization and all the
same functionality that I see in Android
and anything about Windows Phone 8 but
I'm gonna give it a shot I gave it a
full fair shot and I think it's
important to note where I'm coming from
and where I see this device from so that
me further adue is good take a look at
the Nokia Lumia 925 so first of all on
the outside this thing has pretty great
hardware it's up there in the top 5 best
built smartphones you can get right now
alongside the HTC One near the top
seriously it has zero give zero flex and
all aluminum ring around the outside
Gorilla Glass 2 on the front and
technically a plastic back but a very
rigid solid build it's also rounded on
every single corner and the design is
pretty nice and it has a slimming matte
finish on that back so basically it's
like a Lumia 920 on a diet
it's slimmer and thinner and more
pocketable than its cousin in every
single way and it ends up making a
beautifully sculpted device now in the
specs Department it's interesting
because this is supposed to be a
flagship device right well it doesn't
have what we would think of as flagship
specs it has a 4.5 inch 1280 by 768
AMOLED display a 1.5 gigahertz dual-core
Snapdragon s4 processor 1 gigabyte of
RAM a 2000 million power battery it's
kind of reminiscent of the galaxy s 2 to
be honest but even at its 1280 by 768
resolution and all that it's it's fine
because Windows Phone and all of its
apps yes all of them trust me they'll
work just fine with what seems like
mid-range specs for a phone in 2013 so
that AMOLED display is actually pretty
awesome it's 1280 by 768 but it comes in
at 334 PPI so it's a very high pixel
density and of course since so much of
Windows Phone is based around this color
on black
you get a good look at those insane
contrast ratios and deep blacks you get
from the display being AMOLED it's also
very readable outdoors too another thing
about the design choice is that all of
the buttons on this phone are on the
right-hand side so the volume rocker the
power button and that dedicated camera
switch are all on the right-hand side
and I think that actually makes for a
pretty compact easy to use device you
only really have to use it in one single
hand where your thumb is you can access
every single one of these buttons and I
think it's also notable that there's
that camera key because actually makes
it feel like a really solid shooter even
if you're not taking the best pictures
in the world with this pure view shooter
on the back and the dedicated half press
and full press to focus and take a
picture this camera button is is really
solid and I think it adds that feel it
brings us back to like the 2010 LG
Voyager style phones where you always
got that dedicated camera button and
speaking of the camera the back of this
device is basically dedicated to exactly
that the decently loud speaker on the
bottom and the camera it's an eight
point seven megapixel PureView camera
now I can't get into exactly how the
proprietary PureView technology works
behind the scenes when you're taking
shots but it is a pretty big deal to
what Nokia is doing with this camera but
at the end of the day this phone is a
great walk-around camera it takes sharp
shots with nice contrast solid amount of
detail pretty good low-light performance
I would say and it also happens to have
really good stabilization I noticed
especially when zooming in and when
taking video but at the end of the day
it's about on par with any other
high-end 8 megapixel camera which makes
sense so the hardware is essentially a
mid-range inside with beautifully
sculpted externals so how about that
software well it's alright it's alright
the Lumia 925 like we said is running
Windows Phone 8 the latest version and
the operating system itself is pretty
unique and a lot of ways that a lot of
people will like but it's also missing a
lot of things that a lot of people have
gotten used to having in other OSS
namely the apps but we'll get to that in
a second so it's pretty minimalist style
operating system overall as you can see
pretty easy on the eye is very text
heavy and overall pretty easy to get
used to using it goes exactly as you'd
expect everything does what you expect
it to so the ease of use factor is
pretty great and I could probably give
this to my parents and they'd figure out
most of it in about two seconds flat and
in terms of style it's actually
something I can see myself getting used
to if I sign a contract and had this
going for a few years of course if
you're not into red and black like I am
you can always change the overall theme
of the entire OS with just a pair of
flipped switches which is pretty
convenient but that's as much
customization as you're gonna get with
these phones so if you like making the
device your own like you really like
making changes on any number of Android
phones out there you'll be a bit
disappointed with the lack of UI changes
you actually can make especially with
your home screen in Windows Phone 8 in
the home screen basically besides
changing the colors you can only change
the size and positioning of your tiles
and what you decide to pin on your home
screen that's about it so some of the
information you can see before you tap
it these are called live tiles and they
give a bit of a dynamic look but that's
it you can't change anything else about
the home screen and next to that you get
your list of apps so yeah I'm usually a
person who likes tinkering around with
the look of the Android you know OS and
home screens and things like that I got
bored pretty easily in Windows Phone I
hate to say that but as I was taking
around in Windows Phone I found that
this this device had a particularly
impressive battery life I mentioned
before it only has a 2,000 milliamp hour
battery but thanks for that AMOLED
display and the deep blacks made
constant appearances in Windows Phone 8
I'm able to get some pretty impressive
battery life I would go to say all-day
battery and then a little bit more on
only two thousand milliamp hours and
that's because Windows Phone is really
really effective and efficient and the
standby times were outstanding
standby times are great I could put it
to sleep with a hundred percent battery
and wicked up the next morning and it
would have 97% battery which was really
really cool
but you'd expect a phone with such great
battery life to sacrifice a bit on
performance again Windows Phone takes a
lot at the helm here and performance
actually was usually pretty good it was
very responsive especially with the
slick Gorilla Glass 2 on the front but
this was a little bit dependent on the
app but that's the thing the apps there
are very very few apps in the Windows
Phone Marketplace and in fact I would go
to say that this is this is the killer
right now this is what kills Windows
Phone for me I could use Windows Phone
for a while if I had to sign a contract
but the app support just isn't there
there are so many apps that I would use
on iOS and Android that I just can't
find in fact if you take a look through
the Windows Phone Marketplace you will
see in the list of the top apps in the
entire marketplace it very quickly
diminishes from you know Angry Birds and
the highest end developers straight down
to like flashlights and you know mini
games and just terrible terrible apps in
the top in the whole entire app store so
I mean this is not a great App Store at
all again the interface is fine it looks
fine it functions perfectly but it's
just missing so many of the apps were
used to having so overall it turns out
that the Lumia 925 is a really nice
Windows Phone flagship and definitely
worthy and deserving of the Lumia tag
now if this phone was running Android I
probably carry it in a heartbeat I am
such a big fan of the outside of this
phone and the design and the aesthetics
and the build quality just like the HTC
One the Nokia of all the lumo Kia phones
have in general been really well built
but this one's a lot thinner and a lot
more rounded and a lot more
pocket-friendly than the previous Lumia
bricks so I really liked it Moe Kia
Lumia 925 design and build and
aesthetics and everything like that but
yeah there are a lot of decisions you
have to make if you want to decide to
carry this phone or not that I've listed
out in the review and the choice is
yours would you carry this phone
I think I'd I think I'd be down either
way thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video for the give a thumbs up
below that definitely helps out and the
comment section is always open below
you'll send me answering a ton of
comments below there for any of the
thoughts you guys might have to leave
about the Lumia 925 either way thank you
for watching and I'll talk to you guys
in the next video
yes
[Music]